معنا من خانيونس مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل
ابو عمر اسماعيل اين تتركز العمليات
العسكريه سواء القصف او كذلك
الاشتباكات نعم نبدا بعمليه القصف وهي
عمليه قصف مدفعي تقوم بها مدفعيه الاحتلال
واليات الاحتلال في اكثر من محور من محاور
التوغل الذي تقوم به قوات الاحتلال في
اجزاء مختلفه من محافظه خانيونس خاصه في
الاجزاء الغربيه وكذلك في الاجزاء
الجنوبيه من المحافظه حيث الاليات قامت
منذ صباح هذا اليوم وحتى هذه اللحظه تقوم
بعمليات قصف في منطقه التحليه وكذلك منطقه
حي المناره اضافه الى محيط الكليه في كليه
العلوم والتكنولوجيا في منطقه جيزان
النجار حيث تتواجد اليات الاحتلال وهناك
السنه دخان تتصاعد بين الحين والاخر بسبب
هذا القصف العنيف الذي استمر منذ ساعات
الليل وحتى هذه اللحظه في تلك المناطق لكن
محاور وتركيز قوات الاحتلال في دائما في
المناطق الغربيه للمحافظه تحديدا في منطقه
المعسكر او مخيم خانيونس كذلك منطقه حي
الامل حيث تتواجد هذه الاليات في محيط تلك
المنطقتين وتقوم بعمليات قصف بين الحين
والاخر اضافه الى قصف من قبل طائرات
الاحتلال الحربيه لتجمعات مواطنين في محيط
مدارس يتواجد بها نازحون وهذه هذه المناطق
خاصه في منطقه حي الامل او المشروع وكذلك
منطقه المعسكر تتعرض منذ ايام الى عمليه
قصف عنيف عمليه نسف تقوم بها قوات
الاحتلال لمنشات ومنازل المواطنين في تلك
المنطقه قوات الاحتلال في منطقه المعسكر
تحديدا وكذلك في منطقه حي الامل هناك
اشتباكات تدور معها مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تحديدا خاصه ان نتحدث بان تلك
المنطقتين هي منطقه مخيم ومعسكر للاجئين
بمعنى ان المنازل متلاصقه جدا ببعضها
البعض واحيانا ان الاشتباكات تدور على
نقطه من نقطه صفر ما بين المقاومه وكذلك
قوات الاحتلال المقاومه تستخدم تستخدم في
ذلك اسلحه متعدده ومختلفه خاصه فيما يتعلق
باستهداف الاليات عبر استخدام قذائف مضاده
للدروع من نوع ياسي 105 او احيانا
اشتباكات بالاسلحه الخفيفه حيث قوات
الاحتلال وجنود الاحتلال في اكثر من من
لحظه وفي اكثر من مرحله قاموا بالترجم في
منازل المواطنين وقاموا ب بالعبث في منازل
المواطنين و وحطوا ايضا بهذه المنازل مما
قامت استدعى بان تتدخل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه باستهداف هؤلاء الجنود عبر
اسلحه خفيفه كما قالت سرايا القدس في
بيانات مختلفه خلال الساعات الماضيه لكن
فيما يتعلق بالاوضاع الميدانيه هنا
المنطقه الحديثه او الجديده التي قامت
قوات الاحتلال بالتراجع منها في المناطق
الغربيه خاصه منطقه حي النمساوي تراجعت
اليات الاحتلال وذهبت الى منطقه جديده وهي
منطقه التحليه وتحرك هذه الاليات اكثر من
10 اليات حيث ان المنطقه منطقه التحليه
كانت قد انسحبت منها قوات الا احتلال
باتجاه المنطقه الغربيه لتعزيز اليات
الاحتلال وقوات الاحتلال في المنطقه
الغربيه لكن خلال ساعات الليل تراجعت هذهه
الاليات الى هذه المنطقه التي كانت قد
انسحبت منها خلال الايام الماضيه وقامت
بقصف مدفعي عنيف في هذه المنطقه اضافه الى
اصوات اشتباكات ايضا ما بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في هذه المنطقه وقوات الاحتلال
المقاومه اعلنت خلال الساعات الماضيه
بانها قامت باطلاق قذائف مضاده للضرع
باتجاه اليات الاحتلال خاصه دبابات
الميركافا التي تتواجد في منطقه التحليه
العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه مستمره في
المناطق الغربيه للمحافظه هناك استهدافات
تجمعات مواطنين حتى هذه اللحظه هناك اكثر
من 14 شهيدا في محافظه خانو سواء في
المناطق الشرقيه او حتى في المناطق
الغربيه هؤلاء من وصلوا الى مستشفى ناصر
او مستشفى غزه الاوروبي عن تجمعات
المواطنين لربما المشهد خلفك ايضا اسماعيل
يحدثنا عن الكثير من قصص المعاناه التي
يعيشها السكان والذين الان يحتمون بهذه
الخيام
البسيطه نعم نعم هذا مخيم تم انشاؤه من
قبل
المواطنين وكذلك بعض الجمعات الخيريه
والمؤسسات الخيريه من اجل ان ياوي اليه
النازحون مختلف مناطق غزه لكن الكم الاكبر
من سكان هذا المخيم هم المناطق الشرقيه
لمحافظه خانيونس بفعل انهم قريبون جدا من
هذه المنطقه ومنازلهم قريبه جدا من هذه
المنطقه ف في حالات القصف التي تقوم بها
قوات الاحتلال لمنازلهم دفعهم ذلك الى
التوجه الى هذه المنطقه وانشاء هذه الخيام
لكن ظروف صعبه ماساويه جدا هناك شح في
المياه هناك ايضا
الكهرباء
منذ4 يما مقطوعه على قطاع غزه هنا امدادات
الوقود ايضا للمواطنين حيث يتحركون احيان
بالعربات تجرها حيوانات باتجاه مناطق
مختلفه من اجل توفير ما يمكن توفيره للعيش
في هذه المخيمات التي تنعدم فيها مقومات
الحياه لكن المواطنون خاصه سكان هذه الخ
قيام وغيرها من التجمعات التي يقيم فيها
النازحون مساكن وملاجئ لهم في مثل هذه
الاغطيه كما تشاهدون هي اغطيه من النايلون
ومن القماش وظروف ماساويه وصعبه جدا هذه
الاغطيه لا تقيهم من حر صيف ولا من برد
شتاء وخاصه نحن نتحدث الان في منطقه معرضه
بين الحين والاخر لعمليات قصف نحن قريبين
جدا من المنطقه الشرقيه لمحافظه خرونس
ويعني عمليات القصف لو طالت هذه المناطق
بالتاكيد شضايا صواريخ وكذلك اطلاق النار
قد تصل الى هذه الخيام وتعرض حياه
المواطنين
داخل الشديد من خان يونس مراسل الجزيره
اسماعيل ابو عمر شكرا جزيلا لك